en los vídeos pasados habíamos concluido
la importancia de esta fórmula que decía
algo así decía el peso de una acción más
la opción de venta también de esta
acción y todo esto era igual porque era
una igualdad tenemos una fórmula era
igual a la opción de compra y si estamos
hablando de la acción de la acción de la
acción pues esta opción de compra
también de la acción más los bonos que
tuviéramos este bono valía su precio de
ejercicio y además tendría que tener la
misma fecha de vencimiento ya todo esto
le llamábamos un diagrama de pago en
este vídeo lo que quiero hacer es
aclarar dos puntos por lo tanto voy a
graficar lo para que sea mucho más claro
este va a ser el eje del precio de la
acción mientras que este otro eje va a
ser del valor de tus pertenencias o tus
posiciones y bueno cómo se va a ver este
diagrama supongamos que nosotros tenemos
aquí nuestro precio ejercicio que va a
ser este de aquí y después tenemos un
valor fijo el cual al llegar al precio
del ejercicio se dispara aumenta su
valor y entonces este diagrama puede
funcionar para cualquiera de los dos ya
sea para la acción más la opción de
venta o ayudado caso para la opción de
compra más el bono
y bueno el primer punto que quiero
aclarar es que esto funciona siempre
para las europeas para las opciones de
compra europeas y bueno no solamente
opciones de compra entre mis opciones de
venta entonces le voy a poner las
opciones europeas y es que para las
opciones europeas tú puedes estar
completamente seguro de que solamente
ellos pueden ejercer en la fecha de
vencimiento el cambio con las opciones
americanas tú puedes toparte que alguno
de la paridad ya sea la opción de compra
o la opción de venta lo tengan más
temprano de lo normal lo que originan
más dificultades así que cuando nosotros
pensamos en las opciones matemáticas lo
mejor es pensar también en las opciones
europeas e incluso metro al
procedimiento que hice en los dos vídeos
pasados en donde yo obtenía una ganancia
de cinco pesos todo eso lo hice
suponiendo que estábamos en las opciones
europeas estas opciones que solamente
pueden ejercer en la fecha de
vencimiento